you
hi everyone is Jerry Aman chest calm and
I just got paired up playing a 3-2 game
let's let's go with Knight f6 pretty
flexible start here and yeah let's just
confront their deep on with a deep on
and support my Center not really too big
a fan of the c6 move because of the
exchange Slav to to dry so let's see
probably just castle yeah that's castle
probably night cc3 delaying the bishop
move now hmm let's I'm thinking about h6
or be 60 let's go with hmm let's go with
B 6 yeah let's try and make it a little
bit sharp preparing a fein keto and also
an expansion with c5 I think I have a
couple ways I could take i'm going to go
i'm going to go with the pond and look
for c5 i may try to get in a queen side
majority with a 6b five or i should say
first c5c for a 6b five be 4 and it's
pretty uncommon move i would think huh
ok ah i could not place c 6 or bishop to
be seven let's just pick one now let's
go with this this may seem awkward to
eventually place c 6 okay they're really
reinforcing their center ok let's ask
that Bishop a question I maybe should
have done this a little bit sooner well
that's surprising ok so I mean sometimes
you'll see this capture with why then
going
or with the queenside castling but not
in this case so I think I think this is
an important move c6 and I may look to
rear up my bishop to a better square but
maybe I should get a little bit more
development in queen d sixes may be an
idea I'd really like to have my bishop
on d6 here let's start with something
useful get another piece involved rook
to e8 and maybe a quick Bishop e7 to
hear night d6 not sure what they're
doing the rook let's get this night move
in first notice I'm going with this
first because if I play Bishop e7 maybe
the night jumps into e5 and then it
could be supported with f4 okay the only
thing I could think about here is that
white is prepping this advance huh so if
i play Bishop here efore hits I guess
maybe I'm okay with that though because
I'll have control over d5 you know can
move my bishop hit the night and then
think about Knight f6 into d5 okay get
my bishop here I'm pointing at each to
Queen h4 might be an idea maybe I could
do that just to provoke some weakness or
none let's actually just go with this
it's a nice natural square for the night
and now they're turning their attention
to the C file something I thought would
come much sooner huh not sure what to do
here let's now
do that hmm let's just make a move I'm
trying to provoke us some weakness here
maybe I should have inserted queen age
four and then back although I don't know
how big of a weakness g3 would be in its
defense let's look to play on the on
this side of the board to watch for some
exchange sacrifice on c6 that might
happen if a 4 a 5 that weakens b5 let's
go forward once more if they play h3
maybe then I think about backing my
bishop up and then playing queen to d6 I
may want to coordinate my rooks a little
better though ok let's get this move in
actually maybe King g7 rook h8 h 3 they
have some concern about their back rank
I didn't consider this move I should
have huh ok yeah that's not that's not
cool maybe Queen d7 they're going to
move their night soon rook to ca I
really don't want to take this night I
like my bishop on d6 I need support
though hmm ok yeah this could be a
problem maybe I should think about c5
and now maybe it's just too late ok i'm
not i'm not thrilled about this move but
i think i need to do it and are they
going to break down this square if
they're going to look to reposition and
get a night here hmm let's go here maybe
g5g for a question that pitch
position maybe something quick needs to
happen here let's let's play on the side
it's very weakening move but yeah let's
get my king up I don't want to give this
square up so quickly for night f4 ah
let's get rook here definitely going
all-in right here offering a Kleenex
change huh maybe I'll go for it and then
get off of this file and I like being in
a pin they're going to look to
reposition their night okay and yeah i'm
really not playing with a plan here i
have to really babysit this c6 pawn all
right let's just make sure I don't lose
on time for one let's do this and here
I'd really need to watch over the e5
square so they could take I don't know
how good an idea that is let's get my
king over here any break with this and
it might happen let me let me hit this
night actually right now he's undefended
I could think about okay go for that
brooke check i could da block i do have
that move oh man again ah man not cool
at all well that's what I get another
loss on time I was in such a tough
position to mmm well yeah that's not
really said well yeah I mean I was
playing without a plan it's a it's
really deserved loss they had a lot of
pressure on c6 hmm I wonder what I could
have done different let me uh let me go
into the analysis or not the analysis
just yet
but just before I go with this and go
through this with the computer let me
see where I could have done something
better I do have some experience with
this particular exchange the night for
Bishop exchange playing within this
structure and I do know that the bishop
does stand well to be placed here but I
somehow got distracted with what it is
white was generating on the queenside
this threw me off a little bit normally
there might be an idea by white to
expand with a three and be four and then
in ensuing be five which did happen in
the game but yeah I mean with this
Bishop on d6 and this unopposed Bishop i
should say there's sometimes he could
generate something against the White
King side but I really wasn't anywhere
close really to doing that only later
was I looking at these very outlandish
moves and I don't know that that's
that's really necessary or are good or
anything like that I wonder well let's
let's get a couple more moves in they
seem pretty natural rerouting the bishop
right about here I wonder I wonder if I
should have played Queen here first
would that have made much of a
difference probably I do I do for some
on advanced and then I could return here
I mean in the game what did my queen end
up doing she ended up going here anyhow
and at least I've provoked something he
moved and then then I could think about
this idea actually the thing I'd have to
question of course is the the amount of
time it takes move wise to get these
advances in
but I do see ensuing pressure with you
know with this idea of Knight f6 g 6 h
5h for King g6 rick h eight that's a lot
of moves I realize but when h 4 hits in
this case it will generate some tension
with the White King side in the H file
can open up I wonder if Queen h4 would
have been better I probably should have
just thrown it in hmm what more before I
check it out with the computer yeah
because I mean this is just it's not
really hitting at anything I don't know
that this is really a big deal it's a
upon with some great depth if i play h 3
i'm expecting g3 and i have control over
this but they do have a light square
Bishop around to remedy these light
square excuse me these light squares hmm
you know I think in the final position
I'm worse you know this this move and
now c6 is really having too much
pressure this move i dropped my pond I
don't think I'm trapping the Queen if I
do this here clean here I wouldn't be
trapping the Queen no yeah I got tricky
you know this is something i'll
certainly be on the lookout for this all
night on d3 I know Stan's well but I
wasn't really considering what it was
that a three was doing its supporting
this advance or this a position on be4
if I take it I mean I don't know that
you could really consider this a
liability for white these CC puns uh is
quite good i think you know okay well
we're going to have a look at it with
computer this final position yeah
unfortunately a loss on time but I'm not
the better side here this is the move I
wanted to play off
takes there's no way I'm better here
this is a tremendous night look at me
look at the just do piece by piece
comparison my rooks compared to these
rooks wonderful night upon clamping down
on these two here I'm deficient in so
many ways in this position I only have
one good piece my knight on e4 but one
good piece is simply not enough white
has everything else better okay I have
some space with this h4 pond but the may
the big factors are the file in this
night position as well as the pond
clamping down on the structure one pond
basically negating to okay let's have a
look at it with the computer and see
what more we can take away from this one
okay stockfish show me the way show us
the way let's get to a critical moment
in the game I questioned a little bit
during the game how I should be
recapturing on d5 I think Knight takes
would be ok as well but I wanted to
maintain upon in the center Bishop e6
Bishop d7 now ok nothing exciting it's
not a big fan computer normally won't be
too big a fan of the bishop for night
exchange so on h6 it wants to play
Bishop f4 we have this exchange playing
with the bishop hair but how can i
really put it to use night a 6 ok what's
the idea with night a 6 looking to
reposition to maybe the e6 square by way
of c7 one of these things ok rookie it
can't be bad pretty even as we're seeing
here a5 hmm did not consider a 5 Queenie
7 Bishop here's what I played still
still even a sheer wants to go with the
night f6 right away
this isn't a bad idea putting the bishop
here on d6 it likes me ever so slightly
now Knight f6 this is where i was saying
maybe queen h4 first this is the move i
played Knight f6 how could I have better
followed up let me look at this Queen h4
here Queen h3 that wouldn't have been my
idea to go further here now but maybe
why not if this then queen e 6 or queen
to f5 okay okay looking to move forward
and reply to this aggressive move and
she can't be maintained there but we
know five pretty good spot I guess ok
Knight f6 is what I did play and what is
calling out for but how can I have
better followed up here huh not a move I
gave any thought to Bishop c8 suppose
rook here what's the idea no okay Bishop
to f5 yeah this doesn't feel right to be
perfectly honest I pretty much had this
Bishop hmm you know his job is to
babysit this pawn should some pressure
come on it yeah I was not thinking about
something like Bishop to see 8 yeah
that's a tough move to make I mean he's
then unprotected this and I could move
and the rookies hitting here all of a
sudden supposed something like this I
don't know just something quick Queen c7
another move that rubs me the wrong way
here going into a pin it is pointing at
h2 okay but I guess we have very direct
ideas in mind with Bishop f5 hmm
could I have still played it without
playing Bishop to ca I play Queenie 7
Brooke there now queen d 7 hmm still
slight pull I guess it's okay huh it
wants to go for this g5 move wow what
did I play I played cheat or h4 or g6 in
the game I play g6 and then later g5 so
I lost some sometime by taking two steps
to get to g5 huh so it really it doesn't
mind this idea of expanding with the
ponds I could have been more efficient
is one thing that I could take away with
this idea of the Jeep on push I did Tate
Hagen took I took two steps they're
lying h4 and here a 5 it wants to play
mmm I did I did consider this I didn't
voice it but what I did not like is the
downside the weakness of b6 after the
night moves away then this pond is hit
but huh I have this idea in mind mmm now
this is an interesting point um only
until very later in the game did I think
about the c-4 square and this is this is
something i should have maybe considered
I should have given some attention to
the c-4 square as soon as I back up here
this is this is important each the move
a three for one I didn't realize it's in
it's uh its purpose to play night to be
four but what I could this a three move
influences the c-4 square in that there
is this idea of one day
getting the pawn up this may seem
far-fetched but to get this pawn up to
a4 which secures the b3 square and then
I could already start to view the c-4
square as a result as a nice home for a
piece this maneuver of the bishop on c4
and then anchoring him in there with b5
what will that ultimately say it'll say
that this C file this pressure against
c6 is no longer I no longer have to
babysit the c6 pawn I could take up a
more aggressive post with my bishop let
me let me try to illustrate this I'll
just make some well make some
back-and-forth moves just to just to
highlight in fact okay let's go with
what would happen night there it's
calling for a five here here the night
is set okay it's saying Knight to e5 but
suppose suppose they just take up a
defensive posture play Bishop c4 and
then something like this well I can't I
can't do it just yet because of b3
hitting right away or maybe maybe not
actually be three weakens 83 and I could
take this night but this idea here let
me just get one more passing move in
this idea this structural shift on the
queenside is one I should at least
consider i mean in a blitz game it'll be
difficult but you know i'm trying to
take away from these these quicker games
these blitz games still some correct
ideas like well how you would maybe
improve what would you do given more
time what would you do in a slower game
this is something i could consider this
clamping effect having the the structure
a 4b 5c six d5 and having the piece
anchored in there on c6 or excuse me c4
okay played Queen d7 and you know it got
to be pretty tricky they want to go with
a 5 here I captured and that's where
there's a shift I I felt that but I
didn't know what more to do wants to go
with h3a 5 is an a5 dropping here I
guess they're in an uncomfortable pin
can't really get out of that huh with
rook c7 rook c8 this night will fall
didn't see that idea I just took him out
queena five it's just one of these moves
that appears to be active but I wasn't
quite sure what it was doing to kind of
move fast around this point and this is
okay it's not fun to play as black just
because this pressure against c6 and I'm
of course mixing ID is I'm thinking
about attacking and then there's the
offer of a queen exchange their
exchanged and then now I'm just done the
defensive entirely due to the pressure
against c6 getting out of the pin what
what does it have to say about the final
position wants to go with Bishop a 6-1
move sooner hmm you know i was saying i
saw this much later I wasn't considering
it in the middle game I wants to go with
Bishop a six and then throwing in the
bishop into c4 and it could be as
supported if need be with b5 soon
thereafter okay so Brooke there yeah
this would have been a much better way
to cope with the pressure against c6 and
in the final position yeah it's not
liking me at all b5 is good and you know
this was the
the final position write it right about
here yeah upon advantage it's just too
many good things as mentioned i have i
have one good piece but it's just not
enough I mean he has no good ensuing
moves he could be taken out right away
and it's just a fantastic night I kind
of view this position as if the bishop
on f3 and the knight on e4 are exchanged
and it's a night versus bishop type
position where he's just a complete dud
it's not a nautical position at all
better Brooks better white rooks better
night and better queenside structure one
pawn restricting to yeah not a good
final position but some interesting
things to take away I really need to be
a bit more well of course to play
quicker I believe that will come with
some more practice doing commentary with
these games here yeah but this idea of
the sea foursquare to be a bit more
focused on the sea foursquare maybe this
idea of repositioning the bishop should
we have this exchange I think is a good
one to watch over the e5 square to point
at the black are the White King side the
dark squares on a whites King side and
you know up into this point i played ok
and you know it started to you know play
without a plan around this point 8 a-3
could go for this idea of a 5 Bishop a 6
Bishop c4 something to keep in mind that
Queen side structure a 4b 5c six and a
piece on c4 hmm ok well as usual I hope
you got something out of this video feel
free to leave any feedback in the
comments section below and I'll catch
you in the next one that's all for now
take care bye
you